let's go next to john from ohio welcome
john
hi dave we can hear me yes i can
okay great um yeah i would also like to
talk about uh the whole gun issue
i was speaking to my mom about this and
she grew up in the in the 70s and she
told me
you know she never
uh grew up having to experience all of
this
all of these uh you know mass shootings
and gun violence yeah i guess my
question is um do you think
i guess can you think of anything that
has happened between that time and now
that has
really caused this epidemic to
ramp up i guess maybe besides the number
of guns in our society
well that's a big thing but in addition
to that also just gun culture here in
the united states guns have become the
identity of many
they have become a valid way to solve
problems
for too many people
and that's that's a factor as well i
mean it's both the ready availability of
firearms
and uh the the flooding of the market
with them and the ease with which they
can be obtained
but also the very toxic and destructive
culture around guns it's both
yeah i agree
uh i mean i think
i guess
it almost seems like we're a society
that just
seems to glorify
violence
and i guess maybe that's
i guess one other reason to maybe why we
see
uh you know the mass shooting epidemic
just ramping up so much in our country
yeah maybe to some degree i mean the
thing is generally speaking the
glorification of violence starts to get
into sort of like it's violent video
games that are the cause and i i'm a
little bit hesitant so i don't know that
i would necessarily use those terms i
like to call it a culture in which guns
are seen as ways to solve problems that
shouldn't involve guns and that's just a
cultural issue that needs to be changed
right and i guess by uh
i guess a culture that glorifies
violence i guess
what i mean is uh it seems to be like
maybe people nowadays are more
likely to be uh you know nasty to each
other or
uh be physically violent with each other
and i guess you know part of that is
as you said the idea that
guns are i guess an avenue to solve
problems yes absolutely it's a disaster
quite frankly
yeah i agree well thank you for the uh
thank you for taking my call david my
pleasure thank you for calling in
lots of folks understandably concerned
about what's going on with guns that
makes sense